- [Mike] Hey guys! I've been
getting a ton of questions
about whether or not dogs
can get sick with COVID-19,
can they pass it on to their owners,
and while I'm not a vet,
I'm gonna answer some of
those questions today,
as well as giving you some
really important truths
about how to keep you, and your pets, safe
during a time of quarantine.
To make this happen,
I've collabed with someone really special
It's my good friend
(goofy voice) Da Bear Pup
Hi (inaudible)
Definitely stayed tuned
to the end of this video
cause Bear and I are gonna
open some of your packages
that you've sent to the P.O. Box
Yeah, it's like a pandemic for
me to visit the Post Office
to pick up my packages.
All right, let's get started with Tip #1
From what we know now,
there is no evidence
showing that dogs can
get sick with COVID-19.
There have been a few dogs that have
tested positive for COVID,
but it's been thought
that the reason they're
testing positive is they
have some of the virus
on their mouth, on their
nose, likely from the owners
that they've licked who
were COVID positive.
That being said, if you have COVID-19,
definitely do your part by
staying away from your pet
just in case.
#2
Dogs like humans, need a routine.
They like to be fed at the same times,
walked at the same times,
played with at the same times.
The more you can stick to this routine,
the better behavior you're
going to get from your pup.
#3
social distancing,
applies not only to you,
but to your pup as well.
When I walk bear, everybody
wants to play with him.
But now more than ever, I
have to respectfully ask
that people stay six feet away.
God for bid, they sneezed
or coughed on their hand,
gotten the virus on their hands,
pet Bear, I pet him and
transfer the virus to my body.
It's a no go.
Try and do your best to keep your pets
away from other people.
#4
Say no to dog parks.
I love watching Bear play with other pups,
especially small ones, like
little French Bulldogs,
but during a time like this,
the last thing you want
is one of the dogs, who potentially
licked one of their owners who has COVID,
then plays with your dog,
and then brings the virus
home to you.
#5
Wipe your pups paws.
Now this one is more on
the really safe side.
If you have someone elderly in your home,
or someone who's immunocompromised,
and you really want to take
that extra step to be careful,
go ahead and wipe those paws down.
Remember, these respiratory droplets
that people release into the air
eventually make their way to the ground.
And if your pups been
walking around on the street,
they can potentially
bring that virus home.
#6
Keep an eye out for stressed out pups.
With kids being home from school,
many people out of work,
dogs are getting a lot more play time.
And while initially that's a good thing,
sometimes it can tire them out.
They also do a great job at
picking up on our body language.
You may feel stressed out,
but you think you're not showing it,
trust me your dog knows.
Some ways dogs show stress is by yawning,
acting erratically, or
even having accidents
after being properly potty trained.
In those scenarios, give
your dogs a time out
Put them in their crate, or safe space
for them to chill out.
#7
Call for reinforcements if you're sick.
The last thing you should be doing is
leaving your home if you're
experiencing COVID-19 symptoms.
But remember, your pup needs daily walks.
So ask a friend or loved one
to take the pup off your hands
until you recover.
#8
Consider a telly visit for your pet.
Many veterinary practices
across the nation
have been offering these telly visits.
So call ahead to your vet
just like you do with your family doctor.
#9
Don't overfeed your pup.
You don't want your pup becoming obese,
and then increasing risks of
all sorts of health problems.
It's very easy when you're
spending a lot of time at home
to really increase the amount
of treats you're giving.
Don't do that.
Treats should make up only 10% or less
of a pet's diet.
#10
Train your pup.
Know that a well-trained
dog is a happy dog.
And there's a few tips
I have for you on that.
First, keep the training session short.
Dogs perform better that way.
Two, use positive, not
negative, reinforcement.
And finally, if you need help,
don't be afraid to contact a dog trainer
because there are virtual
options available.
(clapping) Bear, are you excited
to open up some packages?
All right, first one
is from Manchester, UK.
Oh it has it has like a wax seal.
I've never seen him this excited.
"Dear Mike, I deeply enjoy watching
your YouTube channel in my free time.
It takes me back to my childhood years,
where my family and I
moved to New York City
when I was also six years old.
Just like you, we lived there
for an amazing five years."
High five!
Ohhhh! Some green tea
from Winter Chelsea.
It's a little bit beat up,
but we need a little green
tea to keep us going.
This is from Nebraska.
"Hi Doc, firstly, I just
wanted to say thank you
for your content lately and keeping
us informed regarding COVID.
And I'm and orthodontic
resident with a side hustle.
My small shop is called V Coterie,
and I make enamel pins
for health professionals."
I love this one!
It's a prescription pad
that says "no bad days".
(gasps) There's a puppy
with a stethoscope on it!
Bear, this is you.
Danger Test. If it's dangerous bark.
This is really high skill level.
Look at that.
This entire drawing is by hand.
Awwww, it's a picture of Roxy.
Bear doesn't care,
cause he doesn't want to
miss Roxy too much, but I love it.
Thank you Natalie.
Bear, this ones for you.
It's a pet first aid kit.
Bear, are you excited?
No, seriously, this is really thoughtful.
Whoever sent this, thank you.
I will probably keep this in my car
when Bear and I go hiking.
You know it's very easy
for them to cut their paws
when they go hiking,
and to have this kind of
kit available and on hand,
is huge.
Wow, look at the packaging on this.
This is legit.
Whatever it is, it's good.
(ripping open package)
- [Narrator] Two hours later.
This is next level.
There's a picture of me on Instagram,
I'm gonna pop it up right here,
this is that picture painted on a leaf.
The talent level to draw this on a leaf.
Someone designed an
anatomically, very accurate,
human body with yarn.
That's next level.
It's all sorts of books for kids.
"Hello Dr. Mike, we love you.
I just want to start with that, lol.
At Imaginary Pages we know some of your
patients are children.
We would love it if you'd
gift these books to them."
They don't know this,
Bears gone,
we actually have an early reading program
in my medical office,
where these books are
gonna be given to children
who cannot afford to buy their own books.
Some of these books are beautiful.
In Spanish?
Do they know that half of my patients
in one of my offices
speak primarily Spanish?
"My Pet Wants a Pet"
Thank you so much for all
the gifts for me and Bear.
I want you to check out a
playlist that I put together,
me with all my pet videos.
Click here.
Or if you want to have
yourself a great laugh,
check out my last onion headline video.
That ones a really a
laughting, busting, video.
Don't know what I'm saying.
It's kind of late at night, but stay happy
and healthy.
(exit music)